another stage another showdown Mitt
Romney and Barack Obama face-to-face for
the first time since a combative second
debate at this new york charity dinner
though the competition was for laughs at
their own expense the campaign can
require a lot of wardrobe changes but
it's nice to finally relax and to wear
what n and I wear around the house some
of you may have noticed I had a lot more
energy in our second debate I felt
really well rested after the nice long
nap I had in the first abatement but the
elections only 18 days away the race on
a knife-edge this was a chance for
point-scoring to earlier today i went
shopping at some stores in Midtown I
understand Governor Romney went shopping
for some stores in Midtown President
Obama and I are each very lucky to have
one person who's always in our corner
someone who we can lean on and someone
who's a comforting presence without whom
we wouldn't be able to go another day I
have my beautiful wife an es Bill
Clinton he's welcome back to the program
President Barack Obama earlier the
President appeared on The Daily Show
with Jon Stewart a fake news program but
the pressure on him all too real forced
to defend his response to a deadly
attack on a US mission in Libya as well
as pitch for support if for Americans
get killed it's not optimal right and
we're going to fix it mistakes on this
could not be bigger and erase this close
that's an important plea even in
friendly territory the voters queuing to
see him no reelection won't be easy a
celebrity appearance on a new york
comedy show may well be an important
part of the president's campaign
strategy but this isn't where the
election is going to be won and lost
it'll be decided in a few key swing
states far away from here places like
Ohio Virginia and Florida the site of
the next debate and so this bruising
expensive campaign rolls on at this
point a big mistake could cost either
man the White House Anna Thomas Peter
Sky News New York